ouais ouais ouais
veut révoquer
oui d'accord quand je me promène dans la
forêt et que sur les arbres il y à du
lit la jolie cueille je les porte à la
fermière qui les met dans des vases
collet base à wil en et battre les bases
de quoi des bases de ce france -
d'accord
alors oui d'accord
tagada tsoin boys alors à 2 + 6 + dette
mois à facteur de bplus d2 racine carrée
de cosinus +7 +8 plus albert 1er sur
elizabeth 2 ça fait 3 plus de plus 4 me
speed +12 5 heures de 6 sur cinq égal 3
à 14 sans peur et 116 ha oui d'accord
c'est plus un messin d'accord +1 min aaa
et ce à plus 4 d'accord pas ce gars a
dit allez tiens
ajout aux messieurs 00 cet homme je suis
ravi de 0,7
j'aime présent article 12 il serait
vraiment un an 12 et celles aux
contentieux l'âge mais je suis cantal je
me suis dit puisque c'est 007
on va faire un petit peu de com et puis
après on va prendre le thé et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça 000 qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça xdrive lui seul il c'est
pas toi aussi prolixe que vous venez
faire ici my fashion show tranquille sur
un plateau maintenant vous êtes pierre
richard l'a reconnu alors arrêtez vos
histoires d'espionnage à tout venant de
0,007 vous apprend à écouter mari qui
marie si je vous en prie il faut pas
laisser des gens comme ça
bah je suis gêné donc je suis au que je
suis gêné je suis surpris parce que je
vais faire